what you're about to see
is approximately 12 minutes of virtually
never before seen video footage
inside the bent pyramid of egypt which
is among one of the most mysterious
sites from ancient egypt as it's been
closed off to the public for more than
50 years in fact because of that even
researchers and notable egyptologists
such as the late and legendary john
anthony west himself
never had the opportunity to enter the
bent pyramid which was one of his long
time wishes
however the bent pyramid just reopened
to the public in june of 2019
and i was fortunate enough to be in
egypt this last november in december of
2020
and on november 30th i had the privilege
of going into the bent pyramid with ben
of the awesome channel uncharted x
along with yusuf ayan from the chemist
school of ancient mysticism
and i took my iphone my iphone 12 pro
and i have about approximately 12
minutes of outstanding footage for you
now before i play the clip just keep in
mind that this starts off at the tunnel
entrance which is somewhere between 40
and 50 feet off the ground in fact an
entire staircase had to be constructed
just to get up there
and the tunnel shaft itself is three
feet wide and three feet tall i was
literally squatting the entire way down
which was a leg workout to say the least
and i make jokes on it in the video but
i'm going to play the video clip and
then i'm going to make a comment and
then show you another shorter clip so
without further ado
here we go
just do a quick little
frame of reference at the bent pyramid
holy [ __ ]
yeah this is this is cramped
i am bent more than halfway over
this is unreal
it's this little thing here
yeah this is no joke yeah looks like you
got way shorter
yeah it's
wow i've hit the roof a few times
already
and this is 80 something
meters between 87 meters
tunnel
now if you look at the sides
the precision
slide down
you see the blocks this is next level
pain in the ends construction
a tunnel
carved through these rocks
some of it looks like bedrock i don't
know
i'll shut up because i always know how
annoying it is
people narrate while filming
i just want to see oh my god this is
nuts
oh good i'm at the halfway mark
feeling the legs
look at this are we in the bedrock yet i
don't even know where
i'm not exactly situated
i mean look at this you got that
the lines
[Music]
so yeah this is
look at the just take a second to see
the precision so i'm walking through a
tunnel
of a bunch of freaking huge stones that
are pieced together
leg day bruh
late day
holy [ __ ]
oh my god
leg day bruh
yeah
87 meters or 86 or whatever
all right
oh wow
holy [ __ ]
oh my god look at this
this is one steep
and then the walls look at this
look at this precision
just for
comparison
here's my
hold on a second let me get my
just
my driver's license
for perspective
yeah look at this
all just
block after block after block
and then this is like let me count the
stories one
two
three
four i think that's five or six levels
yeah it looks like 5.
[Music]
let's keep filming i'm going up
[Music]
hey catch my phone real quick i want the
shot of it recording as it falls
and let's just take a look so here you
got the
oh wow
i hope the phone is picking up the way i
see it this is nuts
after block piece together
where this pyramid the bend pyramid just
opened in 2019 i believe in june
after something like
20 years
of restoration which is funny because in
modern times it takes us 20 years to
restore something
that was said to be of constructed in
20-something years
in the ancient times
think about that
see guys this isn't this is in the tomb
you see the design of all this and we're
up so i'm on the fifth floor right now
let me look down
and zoom in you see
like below me they're like that's like
at least 60 feet
and i look up so we're at like up here
it's at least 60 70 feet i don't know it
was a guess
maybe 80
and just the nature
of the layout
all right still going look at these
blocks
stacked in
look at this tunnel
oh [ __ ]
i hit my back
i'll live
yeah i'm totally post this on insta hi
there mind if i squeeze through real
quick
yes
mind if i squeeze through please i
didn't see him jimmy
oh jimmy not very good [ __ ] me
i keep it in my back this is great
lagging behind oh wow
is there a room to fit through or no no
you're gonna have to you know what then
i'll just it's not that far
yeah you only got a couple holes here
i'm doing a full uh video tour yeah
you're on camera ben uncharted x
how is it in there it's wonderful yeah
there's a couple features the uh you see
the breeze up there there's a stone
sledge to the right that used to block
that western entrance yeah port
colorstone and then you'll go up to the
batcave
i can't wait to see what a bat cave
looks like just maybe let can we tell
people back there there's still people
coming up
i would love to get things fly by now i
can oh yeah sneak sneak in there man
i'll try and sneak past it too yeah we
got wrong yeah yeah we have tons of room
how is it johanna
oh yeah
it's a little dark
are you like there really is bats in
here oh yeah oh good
they're going on insta too
jesus christ this is amazing
hey what's going on
and it goes this way
it goes this way
you squeeze my partner sheila how are
you good it's nice in here isn't it hi
connie
todd how is it good
and where would this go
uh that's an airflow chamber out to the
western
western uh outside of the pyramid that's
where the airflow's coming from hold on
i know this is shaky camera stuff but i
don't want to stop recording
simply because i wanted one to see the
tour of this place
[Music]
forgive me
i'm gonna get a flashlight out somebody
coming oh that's my
friend ben from australia calls it a
torch
which i think is great
one second guys
i just wasn't anticipating to be this
cramped
okay
i would like to know where that all goes
and it goes up
that's weird these
these are obviously more modern cuts
okay
look at this so i'm in another tunnel
with this incredible precision
of cut blocks
and i am a few hundred feet up off the
ground
oh actually no i don't know that because
we went down for a while then we went
back up
so i'm probably around the same level
that i was at with the stairs i don't
know i'm just blabbing okay there's some
bat
you probably can't see them
but they are there
those are bats
that's a big bat
oh wow
oh wait maybe it's not there are bats
that one's not a bad but those events
up here
like what is this this is nothing about
this is like a tomb it's not burial
sight
it really isn't you guys have heard me
talk about that a million times but look
and think for yourselves like oh yeah
this is just the layout of where you'd
bury someone and oh of course we never
found a
mummy whatsoever in any of these tombs
but you know
where does this go under these stairs
okay now there's kind of a weird smell
in here
that's gotta be bad [ __ ]
i've been to a zoo before
these lots of wood and then these small
pieces of stone used to make a ceiling
on top of them
as you can see
from here
three or four
[Music]
now that's where the camera cuts off
because it was a little crowded and loud
in there but i have another minute long
clip which i started playing when i went
back down that five level stairwell
which will give you a different
perspective of what i saw so let me show
that to you now so that's the chamber we
were just in
it goes all the way to the top
as we were just up there
way up there
and then we go down this steep set of
steps which aren't even supposed to be
there
look at that because it's all hollow so
then keep that in mind
there are no steps here and when you see
these steps this is the tunnel i went
down and originally
and that's on the way out
up
yeah up and out and so
nothing about this is meant for humans
to be able to move around in
there's no steps there's no nothing
without us putting it in there and it
just goes up
this isn't a maze in order to keep tomb
robbers out never mind the fact that
there's no mummy found in here
it's just something
it seems functional so
leg day bruh
is it just me or is that place
absolutely incredible and was it like
anything you expected it to look like
and you got to keep in mind we're seeing
it as it is today with all these
stairwells that were built into it
and keep in mind that
people have been going through there
doing whatever humans do beating up the
place for the last hundreds and even
thousands of years keep in mind when you
saw that
chamber in there the king's chamber
which i mean
never was found with any mummy or sight
of guy guys that wasn't there so
that whole roof system that you see
busted and the logs laying across it
that was a sealed chamber
so who knows exactly what has taken
place in there and of course they also
used explosives in there too i mean the
place was wrecked so we have no idea
what truly happened there or what its
original
originality looked like but i will say
this
pictured in your mind without all those
stairs and explain how it would make
sense for that to be a tomb for anybody
imagine moving a mummy and a sarcophagi
up where there are no stairs into that
tunnel that goes in i mean something i'm
just gonna say it i do not believe for a
second that that was built with the
purpose of being a tomb for the pharaohs
i think it's a silly idea it's not
backed by hardly any evidence at all
and not only that that theory didn't
even exist in egypt to about 150 160
years ago when a bunch of outsiders from
other countries invaders came in and
said that's what it is
a lot of people don't realize that the
egyptians themselves the locals
populists don't believe that they were
meant to be tombs for the pharaohs or at
least not many of them so you know these
are details a lot of people aren't aware
of but
let me also say this
i took several hundred photos on my
outstanding mirrorless camera so you
haven't seen any of that yet because
right now i'm not filming this on my
typical setup because i'm traveling i'll
share more about that in a second
so i will be making a full
pier or uh video about the bent pyramid
in the future while i'll explain all the
different details about it
and also mention the fact that
the very nature itself of being bent and
how old these so-called experts claim
that that was just an accident on behalf
of the egyptians like no guys
that's stupid the egyptians didn't make
mistakes like that and they could have
fixed it i believe that this thing was
functional
i think it had something to do with
frequency and vibration probably
channeled water and air through it i'm
not trying to convince you of that i
don't know that
but i think this is beyond our level of
understanding and maybe just maybe some
really impressive things were happening
here on earth in the distant past
and now it's freaking gone guys
so stay tuned to a future video on that
and let me just say that i'm going to be
posting another video of raw united
footage of me inside the second pyramid
the so-called pyramid of coffray which
wasn't his pyramid either
uh and that goes from the sphinx the
causeway up it to the second pyramid and
let me just say that i have significant
reason to believe that that pyramid was
built before the great pyramid of giza
which i originally thought that was the
first one and the most impressive but
ben from uncharted x sold me otherwise
and i think that there's some real truth
to that that the second pyramid was the
first because so many things about it or
even more impressive than the great
pyramid and these are details i never
knew about so i went and saw it with my
own eyes so look forward to that
but i also say this when i say that i'm
not on my current setup so if you
watched my recent live stream video i
mentioned that i'd have some details to
share
in in the future and so i'll share it
now i've been living in boise for the
last four and a half years although i'm
in arizona right now as i film this
and i'm moving back to arizona i'm gonna
be going back to idaho soon to finish
things up there uh complete the move but
i couldn't be more excited to be making
this move to be closer with family and
friends and it's just going to help
jimmy to be able to make videos on a
more regular basis that'll have other
things around in my life that are
necessary so idaho is wonderful i i
recommend boise to other people but uh
it's time for jimmy to uh move on and
yeah i love talking to third person
but anyways but yeah so stay tuned once
i have my full setup here i'll be able
to start making video presentations with
all the pictures and slides like i
typically do so i can explain things in
more detail but it is fun sharing these
unedited videos through my iphone which
i thought took some pretty good quality
shots so
anyways leave a comment let me know what
your thoughts are on all of this i mean
again
picture this bent pyramid in the
entrance itself being 40 50 maybe 60
feet but i want to say 40 50 feet off
the ground that staircase didn't exist
it's flat with all the casing stones
like so to get up there in the first
place is something else
um
in the very nature about it
what do you guys think this was
i mean it's all about having ideas and
thinking for yourself and if there's one
thing i always say on this channel is to
think for yourself but
anyways guys i'm jimmy my channel is
called bright insight hit the like
button and subscribe and again leave a
comment sharing your thoughts but stay
tuned to another video real soon
take care everybody